FOURTH NIGHT My God, how has it all
ended?
What has it all come to?
I arrived promptly at nine o'clock, my
heart heavy with foreboding.
From a distance I saw her already there,
standing as she had stood that first evening,
her elbows resting on the railing, gazing out
over the canal.
She was so still, so lost in thought,
that she didn't hear my footsteps approaching.
''Nastenka!'' I called softly, suppressing the tremor in
my voice with all the strength I could
muster.
She turned quickly, her face alight with anxious
expectation.
''Well?'' she said urgently.
''Well?
Make haste!'' Her voice was tense, as if
she couldn't bear another second of uncertainty.
I hesitated for a moment, unsure how to
begin.
Her eyes searched mine, brimming with hope and
fear.
''Well, where is the letter?
Have you brought the letter?'' she demanded, clutching
at the cold metal of the railing as
though it might steady her.
I felt my throat tighten as I answered,
my voice low and strained.
''No, there is no letter,'' I said at
last.
''Hasn't he been to you yet?'' As soon
as the words left my mouth, I saw
the colour drain from her face.
She turned so pale, so ghostly, that I
thought she might collapse right there before me,
her wide, unblinking eyes locked on mine, and
she stared at me as if I had
just struck the final blow to her fragile
hope.
I had shattered her last dream, the thread
of possibility she'd been clinging to with all
her strength.
''Well?'' she said finally, her voice breaking as
though each word cost her unimaginable effort.
''God be with him.
God be with him, if he leaves me
like that.'' Her head dropped, and her gaze
fell to the ground.
She seemed unable to look at me, as
though the weight of her humiliation was too
great to bear.
For several agonizing moments she fought with her
emotions, her body trembling with the effort to
hold herself together.
Then all at once she turned away.
Leaning her elbows against the railing again, she
buried her face in her hands and broke
into heart-wrenching sobs.
''Oh, don't!
Don't!'' I began, stepping toward her.
But as I looked at her crumpled figure,
I felt my words falter.
What could I say to her?
How could I possibly console her when her
pain was so raw, so absolute?
''Don't try to comfort me,'' she said through
her tears, her voice trembling yet resolute.
''Don't talk about him.
Don't tell me that he'll come, that he
hasn't abandoned me so cruelly and inhumanly.
What's the point?
What's the point of false hope?'' She paused,
struggling to steady her voice, but her sobs
rose again, choking her words.
''Can it be—can it be that there was
something in my letter?
Something wrong?
Something—unlucky?'' She couldn't go on.
Her sobs overwhelmed her once more, and my
heart ached as I watched her shoulders shake
with despair.
''Oh, how cruelly!
How inhumanly cruel this is!'' she cried out
after a moment.
Her words poured out in a torrent now,
fast and unrestrained, as though she could no
longer contain the anguish that had been building
inside her for three days.
And not a single word from him.
Not one line.
He could have written something, anything, even just
to say that he doesn't want me, that
he rejects me.
But not a single word for three whole
days.
How easy it must be for him to
wound someone, to insult a poor defenseless girl
whose only fault is that she loves him.
She pressed her hands against her face, her
voice breaking into a whisper.
''Oh, what I've suffered during these three days!
What I've endured!
And when I think of how I went
to him first!
How I humbled myself!
How I cried and begged him for just
a little love!'' She trailed off, shaking her
head in disbelief.
Then suddenly she turned to me, her dark
eyes flashing with a mix of anger and
desperation.
''Listen,'' she said, her voice rising as if
trying to will her words into reality, ''it's
not true.
It can't be true.
This isn't natural.
Either you're mistaken or I am.
Maybe he hasn't received the letter.
Maybe he still doesn't know about it.
How could anyone—tell me, for God's sake, explain
it to me!
How could anyone behave so barbarously, so cruelly
as he has to me?
Not a single word.
Not even the lowest creature would be treated
so heartlessly!'' Her voice broke again, and she
looked at me pleadingly, her eyes searching mine
for answers.
''Perhaps he's heard something,'' she whispered, her tone
suddenly unsure.
''Perhaps someone told him something about me.
Something terrible.
What do you think?
Tell me, please.
What do you think?'' ''Listen, Nastenka,'' I said,
my voice trembling as I fought to steady
it, ''I shall go to him tomorrow.
I will go in your name.'' Her wide,
tear-streaked eyes fixed on me, and for
a moment it seemed as if hope flickered
faintly in them.
''Yes,'' she whispered hesitantly, her voice barely audible.
''I will speak to him.
I will question him about everything.
I will tell him everything he needs to
know, everything he must understand.'' ''Yes, yes,'' she
said again, leaning toward me, as though hanging
on my every word, desperate for reassurance.
''You'll write a letter, Nastenka.
You must write a letter,'' I urged, my
voice growing more earnest.
''Don't refuse me this, Nastenka.
Don't say no.
Let me make him understand the depth of
your feelings.
Let me make him respect the courage of
your action.
He shall hear it all, and if—'' ''No,
my friend, no,'' she interrupted suddenly, her tone
resolute yet weary.
''Enough.
Not another word, not another line from me.
Enough!'' She shook her head, her trembling hand
brushing away a tear.
''I don't know him any more.
I don't love him any more.
I will—I will forget him.'' Her voice broke
as she spoke those final words, and for
a moment it seemed as though she could
say no more.
The silence between us felt heavy, almost unbearable.
''Calm yourself, Nastenka,'' I said gently, guiding her
to sit on the bench beside me.
''Please, sit here.
You need to rest.
You need to breathe.'' ''I am calm,'' she
insisted, though her trembling hands and tear-filled
eyes betrayed her.
''Don't trouble yourself.
It's nothing, really.
These are only tears, and they'll dry soon
enough.
Do you think—do you think I'll do something
desperate?
That I'll throw myself into the river?'' Her
words came out as a bitter laugh, a
fragile attempt to mask the depth of her
despair.
My heart was too full.
The weight of her sorrow pressed down on
me until I could hardly bear it.
I tried to speak, but my throat closed
and no words would come.
She took my hand, her grip warm yet
trembling.
''Tell me,'' she said softly, her voice almost
pleading.
''You wouldn't have done this, would you?
You wouldn't have abandoned a girl who came
to you of her own will, who bared
her soul, humbled herself, begged for just a
little love?
You wouldn't have thrown her weakness back in
her face, shamed her for the foolishness of
her heart, would you?
You would have taken care of her, wouldn't
you?
You would have understood that she was alone,
that she didn't know how to protect herself,
that she didn't know how to guard her
heart from loving you?
It wouldn't have been her fault, would it?
You wouldn't have made her feel like it
was her fault?'' Her voice broke again, and
she trailed off into a whisper.
''Oh, dear!
Oh, dear!'' ''Nastenka!'' I cried, my voice raw
with emotion.
''Nastenka, you're tearing me apart, you're wounding my
heart, killing me with your words.
I can't stay silent any longer, I can't
hold it in.
I must speak, I must tell you everything
that's surging inside me.'' As I spoke, I
rose abruptly from the bench, unable to sit
still under the weight of my feelings.
She looked up at me in surprise, her
eyes wide with curiosity and concern.
''What is it?'' she asked, her voice barely
above a whisper.
''Listen,'' I said, my tone resolute now, ''listen
to me, Nastenka.
What I'm about to say is impossible, ridiculous,
completely absurd.
I know it can never be, but I
can't keep silent any more.
For the sake of all that you're suffering,
for the pain you're feeling now, I beg
you to forgive me before I even begin.''
''What is it?'' she asked again, drying her
tears hastily as she gazed at me intently.
A strange light flickered in her eyes, a
mix of astonishment, curiosity, and something I couldn't
quite define.
''I love you, Nastenka,'' I said finally, the
words rushing out of me like a flood
breaking through a dam.
''There it is.
Now you know everything.
Now you'll see whether you can go on
speaking to me as you did before, whether
you can listen to what I have to
say.'' I spread my arms helplessly, as if
to surrender to the truth I had just
confessed.
She stared at me for a moment, her
expression unreadable.
Then, to my astonishment, she said, ''Well, what
then?'' Her voice was calm, even thoughtful.
''What of it?
I knew you loved me long ago.
I always knew.
But I thought it was just that you
simply liked me very much.'' ''Oh, dear, oh,
dear!'' She pressed a hand to her cheek,
clearly flustered.
''At first it was just liking,'' I admitted,
my voice trembling.
''But now, Nastenka, now.
I'm just like you were when you went
to him with your little bundle.
Only worse, Nastenka, much worse, because he didn't
care for anyone else but you.'' I trailed
off, unable to finish the thought.
She looked at me, her face a mixture
of confusion and something like pity.
''What are you saying?'' she asked, her voice
soft yet trembling with emotion.
''I don't understand.'' ''What's the point of this?
Why are you—why are you so suddenly—'' She
broke off, her cheeks flushing a deep crimson.
Her eyes dropped, and she fidgeted nervously, clearly
at a loss for words.
I could see that my confession had shaken
her, though she was trying her best to
hide it.
''What's to be done, Nastenka?
What am I to do now?'' I said,
my voice trembling under the weight of my
emotions.
''I know I'm to blame.
I've overstepped.
I've abused your trust.
But no, no, I'm not to blame, Nastenka.
I feel it.
I know it, because my heart tells me
so.
I could never hurt you.
I could never wound you in any way.
I was your friend, and I am still
your friend.
I have betrayed no trust.
Look at me, Nastenka.
My tears are falling.
Let them flow.
Let them fall.
They harm no one.
They will dry, Nastenka.
They always dry.'' ''Sit down, sit down,'' she
said softly, guiding me back to the seat.
Her hands trembled as she moved, and her
voice carried the weight of her own turmoil.
''Oh, my God!'' she murmured, almost to herself.
''No, Nastenka, I cannot sit down,'' I replied,
standing again almost immediately.
''I can't stay here any longer.
You shouldn't have to see me again.
But before I go, I must tell you
everything.
I must unburden my heart before I leave.
I want you to know that you would
never have found out I loved you.
I would have kept my secret hidden.
I would never have troubled you with it,
never let my selfishness burden you at such
a moment.
No, I wouldn't have dared.
But I couldn't resist speaking now, Nastenka.
You spoke of it yourself.
You gave me the opening.
It's your fault, not mine.
You cannot drive me away from you, not
now.'' ''No, no!'' she said quickly, trying to
conceal her confusion as best as she could,
though her voice betrayed her struggle.
''I don't drive you away.
No, I don't.'' ''You don't drive me away,''
I said, shaking my head.
''No, but I meant to run from you
myself.
I meant to leave, to vanish, to spare
you this.
But before I go, I have to tell
you everything.
I have to speak.
Because when I saw you crying here, when
I saw you weeping, tortured by the pain
of being forsaken—yes, Nastenka, I will say it—tortured
by the pain of your love being rejected,
I felt my own heart breaking.
There was so much love in my heart
for you, Nastenka, so much love.
And it felt so bitter, so unbearably bitter,
that I couldn't help you with my love,
that my love could not ease your pain.
My heart was breaking, and I couldn't stay
silent.
I had to speak, Nastenka, I had to
speak.'' ''Yes, yes,'' she said urgently, her voice
quivering with emotion as she made an indescribable
gesture, half desperate, half tender.
''Tell me, talk to me.
Maybe you think it's strange that I'm speaking
to you like this, but—'' ''But speak.
I'll explain everything to you afterward.
I will tell you everything.'' ''You pity
me, Nastenka,'' I said, my voice breaking.
''That's all.
You pity me, my dear, kind friend.
What's done is done.
What's said cannot be unsaid.
Isn't that so?
Well, now you know.
That's where we stand.
And now that everything is out in the
open—listen to me.
When you were sitting here crying, I thought
to myself—oh, let me tell you what I
thought, Nastenka.
I thought, just for a moment, that perhaps—perhaps
you, in some way, had ceased to love
him.
That maybe—maybe there was a chance for me.
I thought it yesterday, and the day before
yesterday.
And I thought that if that were true,
if you no longer loved him, then I
might—just might—be able to make you love me
instead.
I stopped, struggling to compose myself, my words
stumbling out in a confused torrent.
You know, you said it yourself, Nastenka, that
you almost loved me.
And I thought, what if—what if I could
win your heart?
What then?
That's all I wanted to say, all I
needed to say.
What if, by some miracle, you could love
me?
Nothing more.
That's all.
I paused, trying to steady my trembling hands.
Listen to me, Nastenka.
You are my friend.
No matter what, you are my friend.
I know I'm just a poor, humble man
of no importance.
But none of that matters.
What matters is this.
I would love you, Nastenka.
I would love you so deeply, so completely,
that even if you continued to love him,
even if he remained in your heart forever,
you would never feel my love as a
burden.
You would feel only warmth, only gratitude.
You would feel every moment that beside you
stood someone whose heart beat only for you,
someone who would give anything—everything—for your happiness.
My voice cracked, and I buried my face
in my hands.
Oh, Nastenka, Nastenka, what have you done to
me?
Don't cry, she said suddenly, rising quickly from
the seat.
Her movements were hurried, almost frantic, as if
she couldn't bear to see my tears.
Don't cry.
Please don't cry.
Get up.
Come with me.
Let's walk.
Don't cry anymore, she repeated, pulling a handkerchief
from her pocket and wiping my tears away
with a tenderness that broke my heart all
over again.
As we walked, she spoke, her voice soft
and hesitant.
Maybe—maybe I'll tell you something.
If he has truly forsaken me, if he
has forgotten me, even though I still love
him—I don't want to deceive you—I still love
him.
But listen, answer me this.
If I were to love you, for instance,
if I only—she trailed off, her voice trembling,
and her hand gripped mine more tightly.
Oh, my friend, my dear friend, how could
I have been so blind?
How could I have laughed at your love,
praised you for not loving me?
How could I not have seen this, not
have foreseen this?
How stupid I've been!
But—she stopped, as though she could go no
further, and then said firmly, I've made up
my mind.
I will tell you.
Look, Nastenka, I said quickly, my voice barely
above a whisper.
Do you know what?
I'll go.
I'll leave.
That's what I'll do.
I'm only tormenting you now, adding to your
sorrow.
You're already remorseful for laughing at me, and
I can't stand to make it worse.
I don't want to be another burden to
you.
It's my fault, Nastenka.
All of it is my fault.
So—good-bye.
Stay, she cried, her voice filled with sudden
urgency.
She stopped walking and turned to face me.
Stay, listen to me.
Can you wait?
Wait?
For what?
How?
I asked, my heart pounding in my chest,
as I stared into her tear-filled eyes.
I love him, she said, her voice trembling
and full of conflict.
But I shall get over it.
I must get over it.
I cannot fail to get over it.
I'm getting over it already.
I feel it deep inside me as though
my heart is being reshaped.
Who knows?
Perhaps it will all end today, for I
hate him as much as I love him.
He has been laughing at me, mocking me,
while you—you have been here with me, weeping
with me, sharing my pain, without judgment.
You haven't turned away from me as he
has.
You have not repulsed me.
You love me, while he—he has never loved
me, not truly, not in the way I
thought he did.
And now, my dear friend, I love you
myself.
She paused, catching her breath.
Yes, I love you.
I love you as you love me.
I told you this before, and you heard
it yourself.
I love you because you are better than
he is.
You are so much nobler than he could
ever be, because—because— Her voice faltered, and she
could not continue.
The poor girl's emotions overwhelmed her.
She could not find the words to express
herself, and instead laid her head upon my
shoulder, then upon my chest, trembling and crying
bitterly.
Her sobs pierced my soul.
I held her as gently as I could,
comforting her, murmuring words of reassurance, but her
tears would not stop.
She clung to me tightly, pressing my hand
as though to draw strength from it, and
in between her sobs she whispered brokenly, Wait,
wait.
It will pass in a moment.
I just need a moment.
These tears, they mean nothing.
It's just weakness.
Please.
Just wait until it's over.
I waited, saying nothing, afraid to break the
fragile moment.
Finally her sobs quieted.
She dried her eyes, took a deep breath,
and we began walking again, slowly, as though
every step required an immense effort of will.
I wanted to speak, to offer her solace,
but she shook her head, silently begging me
to let her gather her strength.
We walked in silence for some time, until,
at last, she found the courage to speak.
It's like this, she began, in a weak,
trembling voice, one that pierced my heart with
its fragile honesty.
Don't think I'm so light, so inconstant, that
I could just forget or change so quickly.
I loved him for an entire year, and
I swear by everything I hold sacred by
God Himself that in all that time I
was never unfaithful to him, not even in
my thoughts, but he—he despised me, he laughed
at me.
God forgive him, but he insulted me so
deeply, he wounded my heart in ways I
cannot explain, and now—she hesitated, pressing my hand
tightly as though bracing herself for the admission—now
I do not love him.
I can't love him.
I can only love what is noble, what
is generous, what understands me, and he—he is
not worthy of me, he never was.
Her voice grew steadier as she continued.
It's better this way, better that he has
shown me now what he truly is, rather
than later, when it might have been even
harder to bear.
It's over, it has to be over.
She paused, took a shuddering breath, and then
turned to me with tear-filled eyes.
But who knows, my dear friend, perhaps my
love for him was never real, perhaps it
was all a mistake, a delusion, maybe it
all began as some childish mischief, some foolishness
born out of my strict life with Grandmother.
Perhaps I was never meant to love him
at all, but someone else, a man who
would truly care for me, who would have
pity on me, and—and— Her voice trailed off,
and she looked away, overwhelmed by her emotions.
But let's not talk about that any more,
she said, shaking her head as if to
banish the thoughts.
I only wanted to tell you—I wanted to
say that if, although I loved him, or
rather did love him, if despite all that
you still feel the way you do, if
your love is so great that it could
drive away this old feeling from my heart,
if you would take pity on me and
not leave me to face my fate alone,
without hope or consolation, if you truly love
me as you do now, then I swear
to you, with all my heart, that my
gratitude, my love, will grow until it is
worthy of yours.
Will you take my hand?"
"'Nastenka!' I cried, overcome with emotion, my voice
breaking under the weight of my feelings.
"'Oh, Nastenka!
My dear Nastenka!' "'Enough, enough,' she said quickly,
though her own voice trembled with feeling.
"'Well, now it's all been said, hasn't it?
Hasn't it?
You're happy now, aren't you?
And I—I'm happy too.
But no more of this.
No more.
Let's not talk about it any more, please.
Let's—' "'Let's talk about something else, for God's
sake.' "'Yes, Nastenka, yes,' I said fervently, though
my heart was overflowing.
"'Enough of that.
I'm happy now, so happy, and—' "'And yes,
Nastenka, let's talk about other things.
Let's hurry and talk before—' But we couldn't
find the words, we couldn't think of what
to say.
Instead, we laughed and cried together, saying a
thousand meaningless, incoherent things like children caught up
in the thrill of a new game.
We walked along the pavement, then turned back
and crossed the road, only to stop and
return to the embankment.
We moved without purpose, without direction, lost in
the strange, joyful, bittersweet haze of that moment.
We were like children, stumbling through the beginnings
of something neither of us fully understood.
"'I am living alone now, Nastenka,' I began
hesitantly, my voice soft, as though afraid to
disturb the dreamlike quality of our conversation.
But tomorrow, everything will change.
"'Of course you already know, Nastenka, that I'm
not a wealthy man.
I only have twelve hundred roubles to my
name, but that doesn't matter, does it?' "'Of
course it doesn't matter,' she replied earnestly, her
eyes sparkling with warmth and determination.
"'And you know, Granny has her pension, so
she won't be a burden.
We must take Granny with us, of course.'
"'Absolutely we must take Granny,' I agreed, nodding
with enthusiasm.
"'But then there's Matrona to think about as
well.' "'Yes,' Nastenka said thoughtfully, tapping her chin
with her finger.
"'And we can't forget about Fyokla either.' "'Matrona
is a good woman,' I said, smiling as
though picturing her bustling about.
"'But she does have one little fault.
She has no imagination whatsoever, Nastenka.
Absolutely none, not even a spark.
But that's all right.
We'll manage.' "'That's fine.
They can live together,' Nastenka replied decisively, waving
her hand as though brushing aside any objections.
"'But you must move to us tomorrow.
There's no time to waste.' "'Move to you?'
I asked, feigning surprise.
"'How would that work?' "'Of course you must,'
she said firmly, her tone playful yet resolute.
"'We have a room on the top floor.
It's empty now.
There was an old lady living there before,
but she left a while ago.
I know Granny would like the idea of
having a young man in the house.
She even said to me, "'Why not let
a young man rent it?' I asked her,
"'Why a young man, Granny?
And do you know what she said?' "'Oh,
because I'm old and like the company.' But
then she added quickly, "'Only don't you go
imagining, Nastenka, that I want him as a
husband for you.' So of course I guessed
it was exactly what she was thinking.
"'Oh, Nastenka!' I exclaimed, unable to contain my
laughter.
We both laughed then, the kind of laughter
that feels warm and uncontainable, bubbling up from
the heart, as if the future were already
laid out before us, gleaming with promise.
"'Enough of that, enough of that,' she said
at last, trying to compose herself but still
giggling.
"'Now tell me, where do you live again?
I've forgotten.' "'Over that way,' I said, gesturing
vaguely.
"'Near X Bridge, in Baranikov's buildings.' "'Oh, that
big house?' she asked, her brow furrowing in
thought.
"'Yes, that big house,' I confirmed.
"'I know it,' she said with a nod.
"'It's a nice house.
But you know what?
You should give it up.
Leave it behind and come to us as
soon as possible.' "'Tomorrow, Nastenka,' I said with
enthusiasm.
"'Tomorrow it will be done.
I owe a little on my rent there,
but it doesn't matter.
I'll pay it off soon enough when I
get my salary.' "'And you know what?' she
said suddenly, her face lighting up with excitement.
"'I think I might start giving lessons.
I'll learn something new myself, and then I
can teach others.' "'That's a splendid idea,' I
exclaimed.
"'And I'm expecting a bonus soon, so between
us will be just fine.' "'Perfect.
Then by tomorrow you'll officially be my lodger,'
she said, clapping her hands together as though
sealing the deal.
"'And when everything's settled,' I added, "'we'll go
to the theatre to see The Barber of
Seville.
I heard they'll be performing it again soon.'
"'Yes, we'll go,' she agreed, nodding eagerly.
Then, after a moment's thought, she added, "'But
perhaps we should see something else this time,
something new, something we haven't seen before.' "'Of
course something else,' I said quickly, realizing she
was right.
"'That will be better.
I don't know why I didn't think of
it before.' And so we planned, dreaming aloud
about a future that seemed as though it
might begin the very next day.
The world felt limitless, brimming with possibilities, as
though nothing could ever stand in our way.
As we continued talking like this, it felt
as though we were moving in a dream,
swept away by a kind of joyous delirium,
an intoxicating rush of emotions neither of us
could fully understand.
We walked without purpose, as if the paths
we took were chosen not by us but
by some invisible force.
At times we stopped in the middle of
the street or on the embankment, forgetting ourselves
completely, lost in conversation, laughing one moment, tears
brimming in our eyes the next.
Then almost on impulse we'd start moving again,
only to realize we had wandered to some
place neither of us had intended to go.
It seemed as though our feet carried us
of their own accord while our words spilled
out in a chaotic, endless stream.
Occasionally Nastenka would decide it was time to
go home, saying it firmly, almost as though
to remind herself of a forgotten duty.
Yet even then something always held her back.
I couldn't bring myself to insist, and so,
despite her resolve, we found ourselves delaying again
and again.
I would offer to walk her home and
she'd agree, but somehow, instead of heading directly
to her house, we would meander back toward
the embankment and end up at our seat,
as though drawn there by an invisible tether.
And every time we returned Nastenka would sigh
deeply, and tears would glisten in her eyes
once more.
Those moments filled me with a quiet dread,
as if the fragile spell we shared might
break at any second.
But then she would press my hand gently,
reassuringly, urging me to talk, to laugh, to
carry on as though nothing had changed.
And so we walked on, as though the
night might stretch endlessly before us.
At last Nastenka spoke with a mix of
finality and reluctance.
It really is time I went home, she
said, her voice softer than usual.
It must be very late by now.
We have to stop being so childish.
Yes, Nastenka, I replied, though my voice lacked
the conviction of hers.
But as for me, I won't be going
home.
I know I won't sleep tonight.
I don't think I'll sleep either, she admitted
with a faint smile.
But still, you must see me home.
Of course, how could I not?
This time, she said with a mischievous glint
in her eye, we really will make it
to the house, promise me.
Honor bright, I said with a laugh, raising
my hand as if taking an oath.
Truly, no more turning back halfway?
Truly, I swear it.
Well, then, come along.
Come along, I echoed, but then I paused,
looking upward.
Nastenka, just look at the sky.
Look how beautiful it is tonight.
Tomorrow will be glorious.
You can tell by that deep blue and
the way the moon shines so brightly.
Do you see that golden cloud drifting across
it now?
Look, look, no, it's passed by.
Isn't it breathtaking?
But Nastenka wasn't looking at the sky.
She stood silently beside me, her body unnaturally
still.
When I turned to her, I noticed how
pale she had become, as though all the
color had drained from her cheeks in an
instant.
A moment later, she moved closer to me,
pressing her trembling hand into mine.
Her fingers were cold, and I felt an
uneasy chill crawl up my spine.
What's wrong, Nastenka?
I asked, my voice barely above a whisper.
Before she could answer, a young man passed
by us, walking briskly.
He paused a few steps ahead, turned, and
stared at us intently.
My heart began to pound wildly in my
chest.
Who is it, Nastenka?
I asked again, my voice unsteady now.
It's him, she whispered, her voice so faint
it was almost inaudible.
Her trembling intensified, and she clung to me
as though seeking protection, though I could feel
her pulling away even as she leaned closer,
and then I heard his voice.
Nastenka!
It's you!
The sound of his voice struck me like
a thunderclap.
At that moment she tore herself away from
me with a cry that was almost a
sob, and ran toward him.
It was as though she had been released
from a spell, her movements filled with desperate
joy.
My heart sank as I stood frozen, watching
her fling herself into his arms.
But even as she embraced him, she turned
back toward me, her face radiant with gratitude
and something deeper, something I couldn't name.
Before I could react, she ran back to
me, her arms flung wide and threw them
around my neck.
She kissed me warmly, tenderly, a gesture of
profound affection and thanks.
Then, as swiftly as she had come, she
let go, turned back to him, and took
his hand.
Without a word, she led him away, her
steps filled with a kind of trembling eagerness.
I stood rooted to the spot, unable to
move, watching them walk away together.
My chest felt hollow, as though something essential
had been torn from me, leaving only an
aching emptiness in its place.
Still I couldn't bring myself to look away.
At last their figures disappeared into the distance,
swallowed by the shadows of the night.
I stood there for what felt like an
eternity, gazing after them, unable to shake the
weight that had settled over me.
The world around me seemed suddenly quieter, colder,
as though it too had been abandoned.